elon musk's goal with spacex has always
been to make the human race an
interplanetary species to make that
happen he has created starship a fully
reusable two-stage to orbit super-heavy
lift launch vehicle it is to date the
tallest rocket ever built even
surprising saturn v which was made by
nasa starship has generated a lot of
hype among elon musk fans prompting one
of them to even create an animation of
the starship launch from its reusability
to its sheer size everything about the
new starship is awe-inspiring and
displays a level of genius we've never
seen in engineering how it works the
parts of starship at launch the
spacecraft will sit on top of the rocket
called super heavy this combined
structure is called starship the whole
thing will stand 120 meters or 394 feet
tall with its nose cone and landing fins
the spacecraft somewhat resembles the
rocket ships in comics and old sci-fi
movies and is no doubt an homage to them
the rear of the craft contains six
raptor engines developed over the course
of 10 years by spacex the combustion
happens in stages and the engine's
design cuts the amount of propellant
wasted in the middle you have propellant
tanks that feed liquid methane and
liquid oxygen to the raptors and the
combination is called methylox this
choice of fuel is definitely not common
for rocket engines but methane can
generate plenty of thrust and it works
in a practical sense liquid methane can
be synthesized from martian subsurface
water and from atmospheric carbon
dioxide using a chemical process known
as the savateer reaction so the rocket
can be refueled on mars for the return
trip bringing mars a step closer to
self-sufficiency the super heavy rocket
measures 70 meters or 230 feet and will
be filled with 6.8 million pounds of
chilled methylx this guy will be powered
by 28 raptor engines providing 16
million pounds of thrust an engineering
marvel hexiles first aluminum then
carbon fiber then stainless steel and
now hexagonal tiles the starship body
has seen quite a lot of evolution since
its conception aluminum is a lightweight
material and has been the go-to for the
manufacturing of every spacecraft after
some launches under their belt musk
decided to give carbon fiber a shot but
that turned out to be way too expensive
at least 200 a kilogram so next on the
list was stainless steel though heavy it
is incredibly heat resistant it's not a
brand new concept we did once try steel
for the atlas program in the 1950s
aluminum has a much better temperature
tolerance than anything we've used
before and would be the key to going to
mars we need something heat resistant
because when starship enters mars
incredibly thin atmosphere it will do so
in a way that the amount of drag is
increased to slow the vehicle as it
approaches the surface with drag comes
heat and spacex plans to cool the
rocket's descent using a liquid methane
pump under the surface which will fight
back against the heat pretty much like
how we sweat when it's hot outside but
in typical starship fashion they decided
to come up with something completely new
all by themselves in a series of twitter
posts musk revealed a glimpse at a
spacex test of the hexagonal heat shield
tiles that will protect its starship
vehicle as it re-enters the earth's
atmosphere eventually the heat shield
will compose of several hexagonally
shaped bits of ceramic shielding at
times during the test the hottest parts
of the tile withstood temperatures of
2510 degrees fahrenheit or
1377 degrees celsius hexagons are a
great shape for something like this
because it offers no straight path for
hot gas to accelerate through the gaps
soon enough transpirational cooling will
be added wherever there is erosion in
the shield this suit of armor should
make it so starship is ready for launch
almost immediately after it lands with
minimal to no refurbishment the fact
that they've managed to pull this off
points to the genius in their
engineering the other materials haven't
been scrapped they're all there the heat
shields are only to protect the starship
vehicle not the rockets as a whole as it
re-enters the heat shield is not meant
for the super heavy booster which is
still made of stainless steel the falcon
rocket boosters which spacex is reusing
are made of aluminum lithium and carbon
fiber reusability another incredible
example we definitely can't skip over is
the reusability of starship rockets are
incredibly expensive because they are
typically single use they burn up fuel
in a few minutes and splash down into
terrestrial oceans having put their
payload on the right trajectory this is
wasteful not to mention it's crazy that
we discard some of the finest examples
of human engineering and expensive
materials to the bottom of the ocean but
for the longest time it was the only way
to make them enter spacex their success
marks a massive milestone in spacecraft
engineering if a rocket can be made
reusable this will allow massive
cutbacks and expenses and thus
ultimately reduce the cost of space
travel for us at least that's the
long-term goal for now so instead of
discarding the principal hardware
elements into the ocean as the rocket
re-enters the pieces will be recovered
the rocket will be refurbished and
refueled to be re-launched for another
mission speaking of fueling spacex has
already devised a way to fuel the rocket
mid-flight just in case since you know
space has a serious lack of gas stations
the tanker starship variant is meant
purely for refueling other spacecraft
already in orbit around the earth or in
flight after it's done refueling it will
simply do a deorbit burn and fall back
through the atmosphere to land on earth
inside starship for a while now we've
only gotten to look at the ship's shiny
exterior it wasn't until 2019 that musk
finally shared the interior of the
stainless steel giant and it gives us a
pretty good idea of the massive scale
the very front of the ship aka starship
has the payload compartment where people
or cargo will be placed this part would
detach from the structure as it reaches
space and the super heavy rocket would
flip over and return to earth then it
would deploy its grid fins out the sides
to help it carefully land back on the
pad ready to be launched again if we're
going to settle a million people on the
red planet we need adequate room and
enough facilities to entertain them for
the journey the cruise starship variant
features a 1 000 cubic meter cabin
capable of accommodating 100 passengers
the ship will have a common area lecture
halls cinemas and restaurants too the
goal of starship we have to explore the
purpose of the vehicle and why it needs
to be airtight in concept and
construction it all started in 2002 when
musk said that existential threats like
an asteroid collision or world war iii
might be the end of humanity and moving
some of us to another planet might be
our only shot at preserving the species
realizing this stream will need a
vehicle that's up to the massive task
this rocket cube spacecraft combo can
vary over 100 people at a time to the
red planet and musk's dream of planting
a million of us on mars will be achieved
in no time and what a vehicle we've got
it enables not only travel but also
production on a large scale in fact in
addition to unbeatable concepts in
engineering spacex also manufactures
rockets like biscuit factories churn out
your beloved oreos since 2010 rockets
from the falcon 9 group alone have
launched 114 times they are the go-to
for nasa when planning their missions to
the moon or the international space
station how is it possible for spacex to
manufacture rockets so fast and at such
enormous rates simple answer exceptional
engineering funding even if elon musk
has found a way to cut costs and make
space travel more affordable to the
everyday man starship still is
incredibly expensive so how exactly is
musk planning to fund making thousands
of starships for colonizing mars and
setting up a base on the moon well
luckily spacex has other ventures like
starlink to help with this venture the
starlink project is an internet
constellation that will provide the
world with low-cost high-performance
internet around the world once the
project is complete elon musk will see a
return of 3 billion
that should certainly help with
manufacturing costs and let's not forget
they have quite a few contracts with
nasa so their government funding also
helps out what started as a dream in
2002 is now coming closer and closer to
reality and it's all thanks to the
engineers working day and night in the
starship offices and facilities what's
next for starship the date is always
pushed back but as of now we can expect
the first manned mission to mars to
happen sometime in 2024. the cargo ships
containing everything they'll need for
living there will go ahead of them in
2022 most likely using the cargo
starship variant a ticket on the ship
will cost you no less than 500 thousand
dollars but musk hopes that number will
come down to 200 000 as they make their
manufacturing process more efficient the
first settlers will live underground in
tunnels made with elon musk's own
company the boring company until a few
giant corporations decide to come in and
build some of their own skyscrapers and
make the mars city musk has dreamt of
for so long think you'll make a trip to
mars on this ship tell us in the
comments below and if you liked this
video be sure to hit the like button
subscribe and ring the bell so you never
miss a video thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next one